surprise naomi campbell announces she's
a mom
to a baby girl i think everything is
timing in life
the 50 year old supermodel shared the
happy news on instagram
tuesday posting this sweet image of her
hand
cradling her daughter's tiny feet
while she doesn't reveal the baby's name
she did gush over motherhood in the
caption
writing quote a beautiful little
blessing has chosen me
to be her mother so honored to have this
gentle soul in my life
there are no words to describe the
lifelong bond that i now
share with you my angel there is no
greater love
i'm extremely happy about it the iconic
model's friends were quick to share
a lot of love in the comments stars like
zoe saldana
gabrielle union sophie turner andy cohen
and holly robinson pete praised naomi's
big milestone moment
while fashion heavyweights like
donatella versace
marc jacobs jean battista volley and
ricardo tishi
also left their well wishes and
congratulations
amazing in 2019 naomi opened up to wsj
magazine about the possibility of
becoming a mom
someday she said quote i'll see what the
universe brings me
and later added that she sees herself as
a mother figure to younger models
and in 2018 fans got a peek into naomi's
relationship with her mom
and fellow model valerie morris campbell
i'm very proud of my mother my whole
beings being sitting here is because of
my mother
the mother-daughter pair co-starred in
burberry's 2018
holiday campaign and in a vlog that
naomi shared at the time
she opened up about their special bond
i will be forever eternally grateful to
my mother
she went through a lot of strife to
bring up
raise a child on her own people say yes
it's my
best friend that's good but you're
always before a best friend
you're a mom and we should never forget
that
then comes the friendship that should be
there but never forget that
you are the mother and they're the child
congrats to the new mom
and new grandma on their exciting
[Music]
arrival
you